en Villar vaquera ciudad de mayoría
curva el principal candidato de la
oposición quema el quilisdarollu obtuvo
uno de sus mejores resultados con un 72%
de los votos y sus partidarios aseguran
tienen esperanzas para la segunda vuelta
habrá otra vuelta estamos poniendo
banderas en las calles veremos qué pasa
ganaremos si Dios quiere las elecciones
están en la mente de todos y con una
taza de abstención superior a la media
nacional estos jóvenes votantes animan a
todos a depositar su voto el próximo
domingo
el principal objetivo para nosotros en
el kurdistán y en Turquía en general es
crear condiciones para la democracia
para no estar nerviosos todo el tiempo
para no tener que pensar en nuestra
supervivencia todo el tiempo
si nada cambia el 28 de mayo tendré
mucho miedo tendré que salir menos
hablar menos quizás seamos aún menos
libres que antes
esta región abota principalmente al
partido procurdo sus miembros se han
presentado recientemente bajo una
bandera diferente por si intentan
ilegalizar su partido obtuvieron menos
escaños en el parlamento que en 2018
ahora este partido de izquierdas debe
pedir a sus seguidores que voten a un
candidato que ha dado un giro brusco a
la derecha de volver a los sirios a su
país eliminar la amenaza del terrorismo
promesas que suele hacer el partido
gobernante contra los militantes kurdos
este tipo de discurso no se ajusta a los
valores en nuestro partido creo que es
una estrategia de campaña Podría tener
un efecto negativo en los votantes
kurdos pero como la primera vuelta creo
que obedecerán las instrucciones del
partido pero ya sabes sea que otro
apoyaríamos a cualquiera contra el
presidente
la coalición
formó una alianza con un partido
islamista kurdo el uda par ninguno de
sus representantes locales accedió a
hablar con France 24